okay guys you are never gonna believe
this i i know godzilla vs kong is coming
out in a few weeks but i managed to get
myself an
early copy of the movie or should i say
i managed to find a leaked bootleg copy
that someone is willing to sell me on
the internet
huh all right let's looks a little beat
up i thought the title was different
maybe that was just an early draft
anyway let's check this thing out
uh odd choice feels a bit lo-fi but
maybe they were looking for something
different
okay drop it
oh this this is the original
godzilla vs king kong i yep okay
[Music]
gotta say i don't hate it
internet welcome to film theory the show
that's more fun than a barrel full of
giant prehistoric ape-like cryptids you
know it's been a tough couple of years
for legendary pictures big budget
monster verse franchise
after audiences got so annoyed at
godzilla not showing up for more than a
few minutes of his own movie back in
they paid him back by not showing up at
all for his significantly more exciting
sequel king of the monsters in 2019
boom get dunked on godzilla the only
thing that's reliably able to take you
down is poor box office earnings
fortunately for godzilla company though
the studio was already well into
production on the next movie at that
point but then world events shut down
theaters and now only by the grace of
our corporate masters at a t and warner
brothers can we finally see godzilla vs
kong the way
any iconic summer blockbuster battle
between two 400-foot monsters was meant
to be watched two and a half inches high
on our phones this is a movie that's
already raising a bunch of questions why
are they fighting
when did kong get so much bigger why
didn't this happen years ago alongside
civil war and batman v
superman side note is this whole thing
gonna get resolved by both of them
knowing someone named mothra
mothra why did you say that name
but we all know what the big question is
in these sorts of movies who's gonna win
well if you know the channel you know
that we're gonna do our darndest to
answer this one early and if you don't
know the channel consider subscribing
for mind-blowing theories each and every
week that'll make you look smart in
front of all your friends now then let's
start answering our question by having a
look at both of our competitors
according to the monsterverse canon this
incarnation of godzilla is 393 feet tall
or about 120 meters
not counting the additional 189 feet or
57.6 meters of his tail
and he weighs in at approximately 99
634 tons making him unquestionably the
largest version of godzilla ever
depicted in live action
by contrast kong was only 104 feet tall
or 35 meters when we last saw him in
kong skull island which is
pretty big but only a fourth of
godzilla's size however it seems like
he's gotten himself
a lot bigger considering that in the new
movie's trailer they stand next to each
other on some aircraft carriers and kong
is at godzilla's eye level if not even
taller man looking at this scene just
makes me think the real winner of this
battle is any boat able to float while
000 ton creatures duke it out on the
deck now knowing these rough statistics
we can use science
to see which creature is gonna pack a
bigger punch analyze what godzilla's
heat gray weapon does and doesn't
destroy so we can see the temperature
estimate look at overall differences
between the mammalian brain and the
reptile brain to see whose strategy is
gonna win
except there's one major problem with
all of that if i'm using science well
science says that both these creatures
would lose because they can't possibly
exist in the first place you know those
fun-ruining laws of science that get in
the way of
say explosions in space or sound in
space or
literally everything to do with space
giant monster movies tend to smack head
first and all those fun ruining laws of
science mainly physics problems like the
square cube law
that's the mathematical principle
discovered by galileo in 1638 that says
that
mass increases at a faster rate than
size basically as
area squares mass cubes and this becomes
a problem when you consider that the
strength of a muscle or bone is roughly
the function of its area but
weight is a function of volume so let's
say you double a monkey's height while
keeping it the same shape you wind up
with four times the muscle power
moving eight times the mass that as
you might imagine just isn't gonna work
an organism can only scale up a certain
amount before all the other forces of
physics and thermodynamics cause it to
collapse in on itself
neither kong nor godzilla would be able
to grow to their respective sizes
if they existed at that size gravity
would break their bones
if their bones were somehow strong
enough gravity would pull the flesh and
organs
off those bones if their entire bodies
were strong enough they'd collapse
into the earth itself and even if you
negated those issues it is
mathematically inconceivable that kong
would consume enough nutrients and water
to sustain himself each and every day
so while i'd love to science my way into
an answer for this one the suspension of
disbelief here is so extreme that you'd
need like a wizard or a fairy or some
level of literal
magic to even approach working this out
fortunately for us that's exactly what
we have see the japanese kaiju genre and
this monster verse in particular has
really leaned into the mishmash of
atomic age sci-fi gothic mad science and
straight-up folklore to justify the
handwavion it takes to get onto the
stompy stompy sure
most of the friends and foes of godzilla
gamera and the rest are supposed to be
dinosaurs mutations or aliens from outer
space but more than a few
are also identified as legendary
supernatural creatures demons
spirits even literal gods all the
legends
the stars they're true
they really were the first gods in fact
godzilla gets his name in the original
1954 movie from local legend
about a sea monster so even in his
earliest appearance he's equal parts
regional
folklore and atomic monster and that mix
has persisted throughout all of his
incarnations the 1990s japanese reboot
series retcon godzilla's origin to be a
normal dinosaur who protected japanese
soldiers stationed on an island in world
war ii but he's also a karmic force
punishing the many saved for spending
their lives in pursuit of capitalist
greed
sir you must leave your office it's in
your way
yes i know that i nearly died on lagus
island
along with my entire garrison but the
dinosaur saved us all
and all of that prosperity i built now
being destroyed by the same dinosaur at
this moment
and there's nothing i can do about it
it's very ironic don't you think
[Music]
wow that is uh that is deep for a movie
with a guy in a rubber dinosaur suit
then a decade later the movie godzilla
mothra and king ghidorah giant monsters
all-out attacks
definitely a mouthful featured an even
scarier magical godzilla who was
made of dead people no really in that
version godzilla is inhabited by the
angry souls of
everyone who was killed in the pacific
during world war ii and he's come to
stop japan into rubble as punishment for
them joining the war
in the first place each and every time
in these movies sure there is science
involved godzilla
is the atomic monster after all but more
so the stories are resolved via folklore
king kong is largely the same way in the
original 1933 film he's a god who
demands sacrifices from skull island's
indigenous people
and again in the original king kong vs
godzilla from 1962
uncomfortable
[Music]
paradise wait did did he just say
uncomfortable
do you mean incomparable uncomfortable
just makes it seem like king kong has a
mild case of jock itch anyway
time and again we see these creatures
being just as much religion and folklore
as they are
science and technology and you can't
have folklore without
the lore bit and yes the monster verse
make sure to check that box too
cones god on the island but the devils
live below us
and what are they called skull crawlers
why
because it sounds neat and this is where
we're gonna be able to find our answer
in battles between gods it's not a
question of science it's a question of
religion and it's here that things
really start to get weird
all right maybe maybe not that weird you
see godzilla king of monsters reveals
that the monster vs godzilla origin is
tied very strongly to what's called a
singular proto-civilization theory
basically the idea that prior to all of
known history there was an advanced
human civilization with a shared
language and culture that
fell somehow and whose scattered
population subsequently founded
all the different human societies that
come later these are your classic
legends like atlantis and the tower of
babel and the theory is meant to explain
how societies that never met
somehow have weird similarities like why
all the old-timey cultures were so into
building pyramids why the same monsters
exist in the mythology of all corners of
the earth and why every culture
somehow inexplicably loves minecraft
looks egyptian
a roman no this is something different
this is way older now no legitimate
historian really takes this theory
seriously but it's treated as real
in this latest incarnation of the
monster verse and one of the hallmarks
of this theory is that many ancient
religions have a common theme of the new
gods sweeping in to overthrow the old
and ugly false gods that came before
like zeus and the olympians defeating
the titans or the viking gods against
the frost giants in fact
even some ancient versions of the book
of genesis described noah's flood as
happening to destroy half-human
half-angel giants called nephilim who
tried to usurp the hebrew god
these proto-civilization ideas also tend
to come bundled with hollow earth
theories in which the old gods
or losing civilization is then forced to
retreat underground now in the movies
the character dr serzawa has a film
theory of his own based on all of this
it's not just a cute nickname godzilla
and all his big buddies are
literally the titans as in the original
true gods of this fallen
proto-civilization and since he is a
very serious scientist with a very very
silly theory in a godzilla movie he
turns out to be exactly right
these are not monsters they are animals
rising to reclaim a wall that was once
theirs but wait if godzilla is a titan
and titans are the old gods who
generally
lose and get driven underground in all
the creation myths and kong
is also a god by his people and he lives
on the surface
and his main possibly only job on skull
island was beating up lizards that come
up from the underground then godzilla vs
kong
isn't just a title fight it's a rematch
and the movie seems to back this up the
first post-credit scene in king of the
monsters implies that this fight has
happened before
and the trailer for the new movie
features a lot of talk about a war
in the past tense the myths are real
there was a war
given everything that we just talked
about we know who won the battle the
first time
kong he's the one on the surface he's
the one retrieving his former battle axe
in short he
has beaten godzilla before so godzilla
is coming into this thing with a loss
already on the board does that thereby
mean that kong is the favorite to win
well yeah actually it fits with
mythology and it fits narratively given
the fact that godzilla
just had a massive victory in king of
the monsters he is due
for a loss but i think our biggest proof
for what's actually gonna happen in this
movie
comes from the original king kong vs
godzilla from back in 1962.
you see friends it's easy to overlook
amidst all the urban destruction but
these sorts of crossover movies are like
the hype house of cinema
you get a bunch of loud monsters
together for a collab so that they can
all get more popular
and this was true in that first movie
back in 1962
kong was the much more well-known and
popular monster
godzilla had only appeared in two movies
before that and number two hadn't been
nearly as well received as the first
in fact king kong vs godzilla only
happened because a super shady hollywood
producer
em borrowed an incomplete production
concept called king kong vs frankenstein
and then ran off to japan to produce a
different
unapproved version using godzilla
instead of frank by the time the studios
back in the us who actually owned kong
caught wind of this and took him back
king kong vs godzilla was already a
gigantic worldwide hit and godzilla had
become
a household name with the company toho
cranking out godzilla sequels and
has never really stopped since but in
the movie neither one
actually loses godzilla kinda loses
because he disappears and kong is the
one seen swimming off into the sunset
but neither one is officially
a loser here and you see friends that is
where this whole thing starts coming
together
you see the real win for the studio here
isn't about who wins
it's that neither monster loses losing
implies that one fan base is right and
one fan base is wrong
one set of merch is cooler than the
other one franchise continues on
successfully while the other kinda dies
because it lost in the last one and the
way you avoid that situation
is to split the difference you introduce
a third-party villain so the warring
factions can team up or
just render the verdict money enough
that no one knows who actually won or
lost i mean i was joking about it before
but batman v superman couldn't wait to
tell you that doomsday was the real
big bad in that movie and superman
doesn't die by batman's hand he does it
to himself in a heroic sacrifice for
mankind
civil war has the twist that zemo was
manipulating them all the whole time
causing everyone to forget that the
civil war between captain america and
iron man didn't
really have a clear-cut winner even
twilight denied its fans a decisive team
edward versus team jacobs showdown in
favor of them teaming up
against a new challenger the evil
vampire legion which ended up being
all a dream anyway best twist ending
ever i guess
and of course the real villain of the
ring versus the grudge turned out to be
whoever decided we needed the ring
versus the grudge but seriously neither
one wins out in that case either they
also join forces
this also would coincide with the lore
for the movies it's easy to overlook but
technically both monsters are heroes
kong protects our heroes on skull island
godzilla protects the world from all the
awakened titans they are both
good guys here heck there's even this
line about godzilla and king of the
monsters
he fought for us died for us he's not
only proof that co-existence is possible
he is the key to it so
one losing here just doesn't make a lot
of sense and that's why ladies and
gentlemen here's my real prediction
in the trailer for godzilla vs kong we
hear this line godzilla's out there and
he's hurting people and we don't know
why which implies that he's been
behaving himself since last time and now
something weird is happening well in
traditional godzilla movie lore if
godzilla ain't acting like himself it's
because he's not
himself that's right we have ourselves a
new challenger in the ring and his name
is
mechagodzilla mechagodzilla is a giant
robot duplicate of godzilla that's
appeared in multiple forms across
multiple different areas of the
franchise
almost always as either a remote
controlled or piloted fighting robot and
always as one of the real godzilla's
deadliest opponents and while he's
usually pretty hard to miss
being all hundreds of feet tall and
shiny in his first appearance in 1974's
godzilla vs mechagodzilla he spends the
first half of the film wearing
fake skin to disguise himself as the
real
thing so could it be that in some or
even all of the scenes that we've seen
in the trailer thus far were getting
misdirected and
kong is actually fighting a giant robot
wearing a godzilla suit well
a lot of eagle-eyed monster fans have
noticed some tiny spots in the trailer
notice the godzilla-shaped creature on
the computer monitor but definitely a
robot back there
this head in the building rubble where
they think they can see godzilla's
mechanical doppelganger hiding in plain
sight
and while we haven't seen giant mecca in
the monster verse yet we have
seen both monarch and alan jonah the
eco-terrorist baddie throughout the
monsterverse collecting titan body parts
as plot points monarch's secret base had
a muto skull built into its centerpiece
and a post-credits scene and king of the
monsters featured jonah collecting king
ghidorah's severed head
why would that matter well recently
unembargoed set reports have described
that head
as being a prop in the new film but now
quote fused with technology and
historically both mecha ghidorah and
mechagodzilla have been depicted
as human piloted cyborgs built out of
the bodies of deceased kaiju this would
allow us to see kong battle
a godzilla team up with the real
godzilla and leave both of these monster
heroes as winners to continue their
franchises as victors
now that is what i would call a twist so
there you have it folks
kong and godzilla will meet and you will
see the monkey take down the lizard but
not exactly in the way you thought and
maybe if we're right that means you'll
also see
mecha kong too all right maybe not that
one's just silly but hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and remember to atomic breath
that subscribe button my friends like i
said before this is the channel that
gives you a lot of cool stuff to talk
about when it comes to movies tv
and youtube with all your friends so be
the first on your black to come up with
these theories find new shows or movies
that might be interesting for you to
watch so across the board it is a kaiju
sized good decision to subscribe to this
channel and by the way if you missed my
first kong skull island theory where i
did predict all this hollow earth stuff
that one is on screen right now totally
called it i'll see you all
next week